before the president's drastic measures
tonight that he introduced earlier
testimony by dr. Anthony Fauci of the
CDC was sobering and kind of scary to
hear we will see more cases and things
will get worse than they are right now
how much worse we'll get will depend on
our ability to do two things to contain
the influx of in people who are infected
coming from the outside and the ability
to contain and mitigate within our own
country if we don't do very serious
mitigation now that what's going to
happen is that we're going to be weeks
behind we've got to change our behavior
we have to essentially assume that we
are gonna get hit Americans hear that
and they want to know okay what next
what do we do America has gone from
riding high to reeling in just a few
short weeks maybe just a week actually
this dangerous health crisis could
dovetail quickly into a political crisis
already feeling economic ramifications
of it all and indeed some are hoping for
a political crisis you can trust this
president not only is he a liar he does
not believe in
scientific the President of the United
States cannot be survivable someone said
he needs to be that's nice doesn't
Maxine nice it's easy for elected
officials to shout or whatever that was
from her from their political corners
it's that's easy it's harder but wiser
for our elected officials to proceed
carefully and not get frightened into
making decisions they're later going to
come to regret to some extent this
moment does remind me a little bit of
the immediate aftermath of 9/11 I
remember I was here many of us were
freaking out we were frightened and we
were expecting more terrorism can't
blame us
Congress rushed to pass the Patriot Act
we invaded Afghanistan and later Iraq
most of us gave our unwavering support I
did it wasn't until many years later
though that we learned that the Patriot
Act well there were abuses there and
over time and both Wars thousands were
killed and others badly injured families
were shattered by loss and PTSD
trillions of taxpayer dollars were spent
a massive displacement of Iraqis
Christians and others use it ease not to
speak of a domino effect of instability
in the Middle East but when key
decisions were made in the 2000s few
thought about these long-term
ramifications I didn't and few thought
of the potential for lasting damage to
the United States now back to today as
dr. Fauci said we haven't seen the worst
of it we must take of aggressive
measures so that our hospitals are not
overwhelmed yet at some point and we
hope soon as with SARS and h1n1 as we
consider measures to fight the viruses
spread we also need to think longer term
this includes protecting our economy now
this may shock you but I'm going to
compliment Nancy Pelosi
good for her while we should be mindful
about mitigating community spread we
should also try I know it's not easy but
try to strike a balance here where the
risk is minimal the business of America
must go on FDR told us that the only
thing we have to fear is fear itself and
fear alone is certainly not a sound
basis for making significant decisions
that impinge on our constitutional
rights rights like freedom to assemble
free association free speech shouldn't
we think about the type of precedent
we're setting here should we assume
maybe we should I don't know going
forward that anytime a serious disease
migrates here from another country we're
gonna have to close everything down as
one economist said the other night that
could end up being more catastrophic for
America over the long term then this
horrific virus itself what changes in
our behavior will really make a
difference given this health crisis that
we're facing well as some of what we
heard last segment from really smart
people they're mostly simple things it's
important we all take precautions
washing our hands covering our COFF
keeping our distance from people who are
sick and taking the steps that will be
coming out in this new guidance to help
make sure we're doing everything we know
possible to keep our most vulnerable
protected that's right but because of
the CDC's bundling of the test at the
beginning or only now beginning to see
the true numbers of those infected the
unknowns out there they're causing
confusion and concern and no one wants
to be sued I can tell you that colleges
universities no one wants to be sued for
not using an abundance of caution we
have closed some schools we've closed
schools in this hotspot in New Rochelle
Harvard University told students to move
out and to not come back after Spring
Break
there are 24 states across the country
plus Washington DC which have declared
states of emergency the governor's
announcement of no public gatherings of
any kind
weddings or church services or school
events or entertainment events nothing
should be off the table in terms of
closures of events maybe closing all
these schools colleges universities
weddings I guess a honeymoon can still
go on maybe maybe that's all warranted
maybe canceling all these events entire
the seasons of sports all of it
maybe that's the prudent thing to do and
I suppose it also means no graduations
no way no weddings even for healthy
people but let's say things do calm down
by the end of April yeah the virus pops
up again in the fall will this new
precedent again thinking longer-term the
new precedent require that we start
canceling everything all anew and that
means no more campaign events like
rallies no more town halls no more
interacting with the voters our
Constitution requires that our political
process continue this crisis must not be
used to help candidates of either party
escape the questions and accountability
from the voters nor must it be used to
guilt candidates into cancelling events
for healthy people at some point people
are gonna begin pushing back against
mass hysteria slowing the spread of
virus the virus is going to be difficult
but we will do it the president tonight
showed that he cares about Main Street
and all of the American people we all
have to live we know it with a certain
amount of risk we go out the door in the
morning yet we temper that with
knowledge and practical thinking so
let's all be smart let's all help each
other we've been through much worse as a
nation World War two the depression just
to name a few
we're Americans we need to stick
together and we have to be not afraid
aren't afraid to ask questions of the
experts many of whom didn't see this
coming and that's the angle